bentornati nel mio canale
sono anni ormai che vi chiudete la mia
beauty routine quindi era arrivato il
momento di farvi vedere come qual è la
mia duty routine quello che vi farò
vedere oggi non era mia beauty routine
di tutti i giorni ma è una beauty
routine che faccio quando un po più di
tempo
iniziamo subito ovviamente con la
detersione del nostro chiuso perché è
importante la detersione perché prima di
andare ad applicare qualsiasi crema o
siero dobbiamo appunto togliere tutta la
pelle morta tutti i residui oleosi tutto
il sebo modo tale che poi tutti gli
elementi e le creme che mettiamo dopo
riescano ad aster da essere assorbiti
bene dalla nostra pelle cosa uso
solitamente per detergere il mio viso
uso il nuovo dispositivo foray luna mini
3 partiamo subito ad un attimo aver
omesso ma non era qui prima le
allucinazioni era qua
ok ragazzi questo è bello della diretta
non si può andare avanti senza questo
mio dispositivo quindi grande do
praticamente l'app non so come si fa
però cerchiamo di capirlo trova il mio
luna dovrebbe
non ci credo avete sentito pulsava ho
trovato adesso che ho trovato il mio
luna mini 3d può svegliare un attimo
come funziona allora è un dispositivo in
silicone a due lati con due diverse
tipologie di dentini qui sono più
morbidi quindi da parte un po più
software sono più piccoli e qui sono dei
dentini un po più grossi un po più duri
come funziona luna mini 3 ci sono
diverse modalità una per esempio è la
globus mode che è perfetta per chi vuole
una pulizia del viso breve ma intensa
quindi super polizia
trenta secondi quindi vere veramente
super breve perfetta per chi magari o è
di fretta oppure fa sport quindi vuole
la pulizia sia prima che dopo
l'allenamento
oppure ancora per chi vuole appunto
andare a detergere bella per sé nella
nella zona tickle una mini 3 e la vostra
app che vi dovrete andare a scaricare
potrete personalizzare la vostra pulizia
del viso regolando appunto durata e
intensità e livello delle pulsazioni per
collegare luna mini 3 alla pro dovete
far altro che tenere premuto per cinque
secondi il tasto di accensione perfetto
si è collegato alla quindi possiamo
iniziare prima di iniziare magari mi
leggo i capelli e qui non potete saperlo
ma c'è una bacinella piena d'acqua
perché perché ovviamente devo andare a
bagnare il mio viso e anche il tappeto i
pantaloni e tutto quello che ho da su in
questo mondo
ok prendo il mio spumone questo
detergente che uso è appunto una schiuma
ed è molto molto delicata io la pelle
abbastanza sensibile quindi l'utilizzo
questo ma potete utilizzare ovviamente
il detergente che preferite
siamo pronti quindi schiacciamo inizio e
ovviamente sentite che inizia a pulsare
cosa faccio modello mela filo in bocca
vado a detergere con la parte più
soffice quindi con i dentini più
piccolini il viso poi vado con la parte
un po più dura a passarla sulle zone più
grazie della mia pelle quindi la zona
atti il mento
i gangli del naso questa zona della
fronte perfetto è finito quindi sono
stoppate le pulsazioni ciacco miur una
mini 3 è pronto per il prossimo utilizzo
e ovviamente sciocco la mia faccia
devo essere molto carina in questo
momento vero vai fresca come una rosa ho
fatto il bagno anche al telefono la
pelle è super detesta come vi dicevo
andando a togliere tutte le cellule
morte tutto il loro olio il sebo che si
accumula appunto durante il giorno e
durante la notte sul nostro viso la
pelle sembra più luminosa più morbida al
tatto più liscia e pronta per sono
procedere con la beauty routine
io lo sto usando un po di tempo devo
dire che effettivamente mi trovo bene
perché la mia pelle è bellissima
ultimamente stranamente solitamente dopo
a verde terzo il viso applico un siero e
poi la crema ma visto che come vi ho
detto all'inizio volevo fare un abito
ritiro un po più approfondita per farvi
vedere anche gli altri prodotti di
utilizzo passerei alla maschera prima
della maschera però utilizzo questo qui
che è di origins che è appunto una
schiava maschi miser se vi ricordate
l'avevo comprato in thailandia ma lo
vendono anche qui credo che è appunto un
primer per le masche quindi va a
preparare la nostra pelle per la
maschera lo spruzzo sul viso e da questa
distanza e vado un attimino a
picchiettare dopo di ciò
procedo con uno scrub per le labbra io
sono fissata con le labbra quindi le
soprattutto perché l'inverno come si
seccano tantissimo quindi le cure o
tantissimo questo scrub e pazzesco è di
frank badin si chiama leak scrub appunto
c'è al caffè che mio preferito ma c'è
anche era altri bustis e la sua ricerca
amarena ne prende un pochino e vado a
massaggiarlo sulle labbra
fate dei movimenti appunto circolari e
poi lo risciacquate et voilà
andiamo a tamponarle e ovviamente adesso
sono liscissime pronte per la maschera
perché vi stupirò o anche la maschera
per le labbra mi faccio mancare niente
per il viso utilizzerò questa quindi che
le block e mi piace tantissimo è la
first imad è una maschera idratante
quindi andiamo a idratare bene questa
pelle mi rileggo i capelli perché vorrei
evitare di fare disastri prendo il mio
pennellino per le maschere che adoro e
vado a stendere la maschera su tutto il
viso evitando ovviamente le labbra e
contorno labbra e il contorno occhi
applicata la nostra maschera viso
passiamo alla maschera occhi questa qui
è di maria gallone una maschera diciamo
soft mask quindi molto molto cremosa che
però con il passare dei minuti si
indurisce e poi va tolta con una
spatolina la metto appunto sui contro
morti è questa da immediatamente uno
sguardo meno stanco meno affaticato
io quando mi sveglio magari che ho le
occhiaie super profonde me la metto al
mattino prima di girare i miei video
quindi edoardo arriva io sono così e il
buongiorno e lui scioccato applicata la
maschera occhi passiamo la maschera
labbra che è di lanese e non so se si
pronuncia così comunque questa qui è un
alibi sleeping maschi infatti io la
metto quasi sempre la sera però quando
le labbra particolarmente secche come in
questo periodo la uso anche di giorno
magari la tengo in posa po di meno e
super carico perché anche il suo
pennellino micro che io amo sembrate le
robe delle bambole e rado ad applicare
sulle laura già appena applicata sentite
quanto va a idratare le labbra le
sentite proprio belle e nutrite tutto
questo ambaradan lo tengo in posa per
circa 10 15 minuti dopo di ciò rimuovo
il punto e procedo con la bt routine
et voilà o saguato tutto la pelle la
sento
compatta super nutrita che è una delle
sensazioni che io adoro sulla pelle
infatti mi riempie di maschere per
questo motivo passiamo al tonico io uso
questo qua di pixie che buonissimo blog
tonic che ha la c dobley colico al 5 per
cento che cos'è l'acido glicolico è un
acido chimico appunto che va a e
sfogliare la pelle togliendo le cellule
morte ma anche a stimolare la produzione
del collagene quindi a renderla per le
più compatta prendo un dischetto di
cotone e vado a tamponare il viso
ovviamente non è un acido ma c'è una
percentuale molto bassa quindi non va a
bruciare a fare danni alla vostra pelle
è una formulazione molto molto leggera
perfetto applicato il tonico lasciamo
asciugare un attimino e poi passiamo ai
seri
io ne ho presi due perché sono quelli
che uso più spesso sono tutti e due
rivera lab 1 e siero idra e l'altro è
fiero defense questo qua rosa lo uso in
inverno soprattutto perché inverno col
freddo la mia pelle tende ad arrossarsi
e questo è meraviglioso perché va
appunto a lavorare sui rossori sul la
couperose e tutti queste tutte queste
problematiche di chi ha la pelle
sensibile quindi se avete la pelle
sensibile ve lo consiglio
nel periodo diciamo estivo barra
primaverile usa invece il siero hydra
che un siero idratante all'acido
ialuronico molto leggero che potete
anche diluire eventualmente con la crema
per il viso
adesso siccome non fa ancora tantissimo
freddo sto continuando a utilizzare il
siero idra e oggi voglio appunto
mescolarlo alla crema idratante la crema
idratante che utilizzo è sempre della
legge e che la stessa marca della
maschera per le labbra e si chiama water
bank è una crema super idratante che va
a idratare in profondità la pelle
teoricamente mantenendo un uno stato di
idratazione prolungato durante tutta la
giornata quindi mettiamo un po di crema
sulle dita
e andiamo a mescolarli insieme dopo di
ciò applico sia sul viso che sul collo e
non posso andare più di tanto giulietta
col collo alto quello che vi consiglio
di fare sono dei movimenti circolari
dall'interno verso l'esterno e molto
importante l'applicazione della crema i
movimenti nella applicazione durante
l'applicazione della crema so che tanti
ragazzi la applicano come se fosse
calcestruzzo è finito e invece no perché
proprio il momento in cui dobbiamo
andare a far assorbire bene il prodotto
alla nostra pelle quindi sempre
movimenti di dall'interno verso
l'esterno
tiriamo bene su adesso magari non ci
interessa perché non abbiamo ancora le
rughe propria teche più passare più è un
po più bisogna andare a distendere bene
la nostra pelle con questi movimenti qui
sulla fronte potete anche fare una sorta
di massaggino di questo tipo tirando su
qua mancano che sim passaggi
nell'abitudine quasi terminata contorno
occhi o usando adesso questo qua di
benefit ai sei rom non emetto tantissimo
perché poi ovviamente dovrò procedere al
al mail che mi metto pochino e vado a
picchettare dall'esterno verso l'interno
questa volta poi vi chiederete ma come
fa sapere queste cose ho fatto tanti
massaggio al viso tante pulizia del viso
e tanti trattamenti non faccio alter
limitare le estetiste e massaggiate la
nostra non farò parte gli scherzi anche
questo movimento è molto importante
perché perché va a stimolare la
circolazione quindi perché si formano
gli occhiaie per problemi e le borse
problemi di circolazione noi dobbiamo
dare a stimolarla
con questo movimento facendo una leggera
pulsazione verso l'interno dell'occhio
et voilà ultimo last but non least
sempre di benefit il conditioning primer
per le sopracciglia allora sapete che io
mi curo sempre dal ds le sopracciglia
uso tantissimi prodotti e voglio sempre
belle in forma questo qua è un primer
che va applicato e un gel vedete girate
esce questa pallina di gel e va
applicato sulle sopracciglia potete
applicarlo
di giorno che di sera che cosa fa va a
nutrire le nostre sopracciglia le fa
crescere di più le rende più appunto
folte e soprattutto una volta che poi
applicate la matita e anche come se
fosse un pulsante nel senso non
troverete il sopracciglio sparato così
ma avrà appunto la forma e l'andamento
delle vostre sopracciglia sarà più
facile poi procedere al makeup stavo
quasi per dimenticarmi un passaggio
fondamentale e cioè il balsamo per le
labbra io uso questo qui linux
rev.do miel che appunto sa di miele è
pazzesco e anche alle anche leggermente
delle come possiamo chiamarle delle
delle microsfere che vanno anche volendo
anche un po a e sfogliare le labbra
funghi è perfetto da applicare anche
prima del rossetto dei luci dei lucidi
per le labbra
spero tantissimo che questo video vi sia
piaciuto che vi siano serviti dei
consigli che magari troviate qualche
prodotto adatto alla vostra pelle tra
quelli che ho utilizzato io che
riusciate a stravolgere la vostra beauty
routine perché spesso i migliori
consigli sono quelli delle amiche e io
sono testimone perché tante cose vanno
spiegate le mie amiche quindi proprio
come fossi una vostra vita spero che
riusciate a trovare i prodotti giusti
per voli tra quelli che vi ho fatto
vedere se vi piacciono questi video mi
raccomando fatemelo sapere perché ne
potrei fare altri sapete che io ho una
collezione beauty and make up non
indifferenti e quindi o prodotti per
tutti i tipi di pelle e potrei parlarvi
di varie problematiche a seconda di
insomma quello che volete vedere qui
fatemelo sapere nei commenti qui sotto
fatemi sapere quali sono i passaggi
delle vostre beauty routine io vi mando
un bacione ci vediamo al prossimo vi
adoro
[Musica]